amanda is with us in oklahoma i Amanda
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up um so I had a quick
question I wanted to know what you would
do in our situation so my husband and I
were both 28 and we're on steps 4 & 6
because we don't have kids and we had a
fully funded six month emergency fund
and we were planning to take a trip
three days before Christmas to go to New
York City and you know see it all lit up
for Christmas come spend like a dream of
mine since I was a kid but this past
week we took about a three thousand
dollar hit to our emergency fund and we
can still get our money back from what
we booked with New York City which would
be about $700 and we're wondering if we
should cancel the trip and put it back
into the fund or if we should go
what's your household income last year
it was about 76 but my husband switched
shifts and so I thinking it probably
going to be 65 this year and how's your
budgeting going it's not great I mean
we've been we've been following your
stuff for two years now and so we have
our every dollar budget we do it every
month at the beginning of the month we
had been saving since August for this
trip you're saying when me and my
husband yeah I know what you're saying
we he's really he's really doing it with
you yeah yeah yeah he's we both work
three jobs two of us oh you're 28 and
you've been saving me it took you from
August to save $700 well on top of also
saving for Christmas is when we started
saving in August and so we were doing
budgeting for Christmas for gifts for
our whole family and then New York City
so we were to throwing aside like if you
go to the if you here in New York how
long will it take you to put the three
thousand back I don't know a couple
months probably okay and if you don't go
to New York it takes you almost a couple
of points
yeah we only
so we'll be out a hundred dollars for a
tour that we booked yeah don't worry
about that I'm just trying to just say
yeah the point is that canceling New
York does not move the needle that much
yeah it doesn't help that much
it's not that big a move okay in the
situation the thing that is more
important is the fact that the two of
you are working together you are
actually living on a budget you actually
know where you are on the baby steps
you're not trying to trick them you're
not trying to figure this out you had
three to six months of expenses saved at
six months now you have three months
saved right and so yeah you're not using
your emergency fund to go to New York it
was already booked and done you just
have a reduced emergency fund so there's
no indication anywhere in this entire
conversation since you got on the phone
with me that you're anything except
disciplined and wise and careful and
smart and it's also even brought it's
even but trust further by the fact that
you even asked this question to start
with yeah so go to New York
oh man that makes me so happy okay so
much that's what I would do and the
reason is is that you're going to come
home and you're gonna put that money
back and everything and are you're not
gonna put that money back you're gonna
put the emergency fund money back and
everything in this conversation tells me
that you're going to do that in two
months because you have been living your
entire life correctly around this
subject mm-hmm you see what I'm saying
if you gave me one little hint that you
were misbehaving out of control your
spouse wasn't plugged in you're trying
to cheat some baby step because you're
whining about your childhood dream to
see New York I would have said stay home
yeah you didn't give me any of that this
was a completely grown-up discussion
here I'm so proud of y'all very well
done